moi aussi je viens de saint-denis ici
saint denis de la réunion
moi je viens de seine saint denis dans
le 93
c'est mon quartier quand j'étais petit
et quand vous étiez petit vous avez
certainement dû entendre des gens dire
quelque chose du genre ah oui moi de mon
temps les choses ne se passaient pas
comme ça ou bien de mon temps on vivait
à manière un petit peu plus dur
seulement les gens évoluent et le temps
évolue aussi et l'être humain a une
capacité de créativité énormissime
vous l'avez tous d'ailleurs sans
créativité sans innovation pas de feu ou
bien vivre encore peut-être dans des
grottes
mais grâce à tout ça on à la chapelle
sixtine
on a l'odeur du bon pain chaud on a les
chansons comme chantait ma mère on a les
textes de jacques brel
je suis un insulaire aussi comme la
plupart d'entre vous je viens du nil la
désirade perdu dans les antilles
françaises
tout petit il j'ai vécu dans le 93 en
seine-saint-denis en banlieue parisienne
mon quartier comme je disais tout à
l'heure et je me rappelle quand j'étais
petit ma maman me disait si tu es pas
intelligent au moins soit malin trouvent
des moyens et donc du coup j'ai su que
si je voulais réussir il fallait
absolument que je trouve des moyens mis
vos techniques pour retenir les choses
pour les assimiler les à prendre un
exemple tout bête que je garde encore en
tête
un ballet ne prend qu'un elle passe kaka
manche et un ballet la danse en prend
deux parce qu'on utilise ses deux jambes
et c'est par ces moyens que j'ai réussi
à simuler beaucoup de choses et à les
mettre en lien finalement entraide un
jour j'ai voulu mettre ma créativité au
service d'une personne de manière
absolument spontanée dans ma petite
chambre dans les années
2007 en regardant la télé je tombe sur
un type que je trouve extraordinaire
ils m'inspirent parce qu'il me rappelle
quelqu'un que j'ai beaucoup étudié et
dont j'apprécie la vie qui est martin
luther king et en le regardant je me dis
mon dieu comment c'est fait pour être
aussi inspirants pour les gens il avait
envie d'être président il s'appelle
barack hussein obama et je me suis dit
moi français de mon côté je vais faire
un truc pour lui sans être américain
sans être quoi que ce soit juste je
faire un truc pour lui et j'ai composé
une musique très rapidement j'ai fait un
clip
et puis je n'ai envoyé sur la toile et
c'était ma manière de participer à une
globalité et une envie qu'ils avaient et
choses extraordinaires
la vidéo a été vue dans le monde entier
elle a fait tous les jours noël a fait
tour des jt j'avais des amis à beijing
qui m'appelait des amis à singapour
d'autres en afrique du sud en disant on
vient de te voir la télé c'est
incroyable ce que tu as fais ma mère va
aussi appelé en me disant qu'est ce que
tu as encore fait tout le monde me dit
que tu passes à la télé alors j'essaie
de lui expliquer en lui disant battu
voici là est élu c'est peut-être grâce à
moi et ça c'était voilà c'était ma
manière de dumas y parle comme disent
certaines les amis à moi et je me suis
rendu compte que innover créer c'était
modifier le sens des choses c'était les
améliorer voire même en créer de
nouvelles j'ai eu la chance d'avoir mis
la vie professionnelle j'ai été
manutentionnaire dans une épicerie
j'ai été chauffeur de maître je
conduisais des princes saoudiens
j'étais stagiaire dans un cabinet
d'avocats j'ai créé une société dans le
design sonore
j'ai écrit un bouquin j'ai fait tout un
tas de choses à côté de ça j'ai toujours
eu envie d'apprendre aussi de nouvelles
choses de manière absolument écarter
c'est à dire que il ya deux ans par
exemple je me suis mis à apprendre
l'arabe
parce que je trouvais que l'arabe était
presque similaire au créole ma langue
maternelle est aussi français parce que
c'est une langue très imagé
me suis mis aussi à apprendre les
mathématiques la probabilité parce que
je trouvais ça génial et je trouverais
ça hyper cool je me suis mis aussi à
prendre le codage informatique parce que
je trouvais ça incroyable de pouvoir
faire des lignes de codes donc des
choses qui ne ressemble à rien et en
faire quelque chose de très beau à
d'écran pour les pour les gens et j'ai
mis toutes ces choses là en lien entre
elles aujourd'hui le jeune de banlieue
que je suis à conseiller des anciens
premiers ministres à travailler à leur
côté comme alain juppé
je me place aujourd'hui à la droite de
certains chefs d'entreprise qui ont
envie d'être pionnier dans leur métier
et innover et c'est grâce à toutes ces
petites expériences que j'ai mis
bout-à-bout que j'arrive à faire ce job
là aujourd'hui
la plupart de ces personnes quand j'en
parle à mes amis et d'autres devises
c'était jean inaccessible comment tu
fais ils sont venus me voir je suis allé
les voir c'est aussi simple que ça pas
plus complexe et ce qui m'inspire encore
plus c'est la plupart des amis que j'ai
autour de moi des gens incroyables et
des gens formidables
je pourrais vous citer par exemple john
key et conseiller du prince d'angleterre
sur les questions de jeunesse
je pourrais vous parler de l'or et de
mohamed l'une à avignon l'autre à dubaï
sur l'entreprenariat culturel je
pourrais vous parler mon ami khalid
aussi qui va dans les entreprises qui
prend des employés à l'origine pas très
travailleur ayant fait des machines de
travail je pourrais vous parler de mon
amie anna ce qui lui se bat aux nations
unies effet des think tanks pour son
pays la libye je pourrais vous parler
d'eux en julie de mumbai
je pourrais parler de toutes ces
personnes là qui m'inspire énormément
ces gens ont compris qu'ils avaient un
pouvoir de création et ils ont compris
le potentiel et on a réussi à le
transformer de façon à changer les
choses
autour d'eux
j'ai aussi
la chance grâce à mon métier grâce à mes
amis de voyager énormément
la semaine dernière j'étais à tanger et
j'étais speaker face à des ministres et
des chefs d'entreprise pour parler de
l'innovation dans l'éducation
quelques semaines avant j'étais invité à
la maison blanche avec 130 jeunes
leaders du monde entier pour parler de
la place du jeune sur l'échiquier
mondial
juste avant encore j'étais dans le bronx
à new york pour rencontrer des gens
extrêmement innovant des entrepreneurs
qui a monté leur start up lorsque
souffle le vent du changement
certaines personnes construisent des
murs et d'autre des moulins ces gens-là
fabrique des moulins de temps à autres
aussi je vais rencontrer des jeunes et
je donne des vins des interventions dans
des écoles en face de moi j'ai des bac +
moi j'ai un bac + 2
ces gens là j'essaie de les transformer
d'une certaine manière des directeurs de
ces écoles font appel à moi de façon à
en faire des faiseurs d makers comme dit
obama
moi j'aime les appeler et à coeur encore
une fois trouvé un moyen détourné
d'arranger les choses ou de faire des
choses différemment d'innover
l'innovation est certes technologique
mesplède sociales sociétales comme la
plupart des personnes dont six en train
de vous parler et je leur donne un petit
exercice extrêmement facile à faire
rien de bien compliqué jeudi à la classe
ok je vous donne 48 heures à partir de
maintenant pour contacter une personne
avec qui vous voulez beau c'est une
personne avec qui vous avez toujours
voulu échanger
le résultat est plutôt incroyable trois
catégories de personnes sortent du lot
première catégorie de personnes ceux qui
réussissent à contacter quelqu'un
deuxième catégorie de personnes ceux qui
ont essayé mais qui n'ont pas réussi 48
heures c'est trop short et dernière
partie des étudiants j'avais passé un
milliard de trucs à faire
ok
je connais ce fric là je les fais aussi
des fleurs c'est pas possible
cette première catégorie de personnes
qui réussit me m'apporte la preuve
ultime bah voila j'ai une réponse en
email j'ai une de mes étudiantes qui
avait appelé la radio un animateur radio
qu'elle adorait et a dit bonjour je vous
appelle de la part de mon prof de juste
vous parler parce que celle de voir
d'aujourd'hui est bien montré
enregistrements incroyable les autres
ont reçu d'avoir un e-mail d'une boîte
qu'il convoitait depuis des années en
disant m top management il est
inaccessible ont réussi à avoir un mail
l'influencent de ce petit groupe de
personnes sur l'ensemble de la classe
est énorme parce que les autres les
absorbent en disant waouh eux ont réussi
ça veut dire que moi aussi je suis
capable de le faire
l'une des choses les plus importantes
lorsqu'on veut créer innover savoir une
grande et une forte confiance en soi le
pouvoir de cette confiance vous
permettent de faire des choses de permet
surtout de garder la foi en ce que vous
faites
moi j'essaye à ma manière de constamment
garder la foi dans ce que je fais et
lorsque je trouve quelqu'un
d'intéressant ben je vais le voir et
lorsque je vois qu'ils étaient avec lui
j'ai bien travaillé chez toi tu fais un
super job
est-ce que je peux venir avec thabo c
est ce qu on peut le faire ensemble et
c'est comme ça que je rencontre toutes
les personnes ministres chefs d'état
chefs d'entreprise pour entrer dans le
21e siècle et avoir un pied dans
l'avenir si jamais je pourrais vous
donner de conseils extrêmement simples
faciles à suivre
le premier serait entourez vous de
personnes qui vous donne une bonne
énergie une énergie créative et
constructive rester autour de cette
personne parce que grâce à ça vous
pouvez garder la foi les doutes et les
réussites de chacun vous vous nourrir
entre vous deuxième conseil essayer
d'apprendre un maximum de choses vous
avez toujours voulu apprendre l'allemand
mettez-vous à l'allemand vous avez
toujours voulu apprendre les échecs
mettez vous aux échecs vous dites tiens
ça ça m'a toujours intéressé ok
faites-le ces choses là entre elles
lorsque vous allez apprendre finalement
elle son sens mais un jour ça se
construit comme un puzzle et vous vous
retrouvez dans une situation vous dit et
heureusement que j'ai appris ça ça m'a
permis de rebondir sur quelque chose ça
a permis de trouver un job ça m'a permis
de rencontrer mon copain ma copine ça
m'a permis de travailler dans quelque
chose qui m'inspire réellement et sur
lequel j'ai une incidence maintenant
grâce à ça vous pouvez aussi devenir des
moulins maintenant une chose très simple
que je vous dis je vous laisse à tous
ici à partir de demain
48 heures en 48 heures je vais vous
demander de faire une petite liste
rapide
cinq noms des personnes que vous avez
toujours voulu contacter des personnes
avec qui vous avez toujours voulu
échanger des gens vous voudrez vous
trouvé marrant voire même pourquoi pas
reprendre contact avec quelqu'un que
vous avez perdu au bout de ses 48 heures
envoyez moi un message et dites-moi ce
que ça a donné
merci